astrophysics is our gateway to
understanding just a fraction of the
vast realm of space for the brightest
young minds on our planet there's a
challenge that puts their knowledge of
this realm to the test it's the
international Olympiad on astronomy and
astrophysics let's dive into this
challenge together and see what we can
learn from it once a year the exam
gathers students from around the world
and serves as a way to encourage
students to study astronomy and also
Fosters intern
collaboration you have to be a high
school student to take part but the exam
covers content you would encounter well
into a University degree on these
subjects this is a copy of the 2019 exam
questions these questions cover such a
broad range of knowledge that to a it
you need to be superbly well-rounded in
your astronomy and astrophysics
knowledge I was shocked to see what's
near the end of this paper it's
something that sets this exam apart from
any Astron exam I've ever taken it's not
just enough here to memorize some
equations and plug in some numbers the
last page of this exam is a practical
test meaning you go out at night with a
telescope and have to find real objects
in the sky under a time pressure and
with an examiner watching you that
sounds intense but before we get to that
let's start with a look at the theory
questions question one asks for this
list of 11 astronomy related events to
be put in chronological order so what do
you think came first some options
include the discovery of the planet
Uranus the discovery of the first
planetary nebula or the first successful
measurement of stellar parallax and then
what was the most recent the discovery
of the expansion of the universe Viking
probes landing on mars or the launch of
the Hubble Space Telescope in the answer
the first event was the discovery of the
planetary nebula and the last last event
was the launch of Hubble pause to read
the rest of the order question two is
about a measurement made in
1919 of staright that was deflected from
its path by a small angle as it passed
by close to the Sun the amount of
deflection is said to be proportional to
the mass of the Sun and the distance
away that the light passes it multiplied
by a few constants the question asks if
it would be possible to detect a
deflection of light that passed close by
Jupiter or the moon to solve this you
need to recognize that the distance to
be used in the formula is the radius of
the body and then compare your estimated
angle of deflection against the present
day accuracy of this technique which is
0.1
MCS with that accuracy you would indeed
be able to see light deflected by
Jupiter but not from the Moon as the
Moon is not massive enough to bend the
light a detectable amount in 2019 the
exam was held in Hungary and you can see
a local reference in question six it is
about European satellites named Sentinel
2 and shows two images taken by the
satellites of a chimney in Hungary which
is the third tallest building in the
country one image was taken in June near
the time of Summer Solstice when the
North Pole is tilted closest to the Sun
and one image was taken in December near
the time of winter solstice where the
North Pole is tilted furthest away from
the sun we are asked to tell which image
is which or as they say which date do we
expect the shadow to be longer see if
you can get it would the chimney have a
longer shadow in June or December the
answer is December that's their winter
and the sun elevation is lower in Winter
leading to longer Shadows this question
continues on and gets harder and much
more mathematical
when students are asked to then estimate
the height of the chimney using the
shadow length it isn't as simple as
Pythagoras and instead involves
estimating the elevation angle of the
sun using a triger identity and solving
a quadratic equation there's a link in
the description to the solutions
document if you want to try it yourself
other interesting questions after this
one cover the effects of sunspots the
changing brightness of variable Stars
finding the distance to a Galaxy cluster
based on the velocities of the galaxies
inside it and seeing if it would be
possible to photograph a Hungarian Nano
satellite from the ground before it
burned up in the atmosphere these
questions are hard because they require
tricky conversions between units and a
seemingly impossible to remember array
of various formula and equations the
next section of the exam is more intense
as it is Data analysis with questions
that more closely resemble what research
astronomy might look like sifting
through observational data to find
patterns someone who works as an
astronomer would likely spend their time
at a computer writing programs and
processing images of stars or galaxies
often taken by other people using huge
groundbased or even space telescopes a
professional astronomer could get away
with never operating a small backyard
telescope themselves unless they wanted
to for fun but in this exam that
knowledge is essential and it's actually
nice to see promoting what sometimes
feels like a forgotten art in
observational task one you get 5 minutes
to align a finderscope so that what it
shows in its crossair is the same as
what you see in the main eyepiece then
you get 10 minutes to observe the planet
Saturn you have to find and mark the
position of Saturn's moon Titan and show
the orientation of Saturn's ring rings I
recently got a telescope again after
years without having one and relearning
how to use it brought back a lot of
memories for me of times when I used to
do this often I couldn't believe how
many nights I had let pass without
looking at Saturn or seeing the things
that are right up there you don't need a
telescope to do that you just need to be
curious and willing to go outside in the
cold but having to fiddle around with a
telescope forces you to be out there
long enough to take notice
inspired by this exam I tried to
complete the third task which is
observing the planetary nebula M57 other
challenges from the exam include finding
a variable star in the constellation
signus and estimating the magnitude of
two stars in the constellation Ursa
Minor just using your eyes this exam has
reminded me why I love astronomy but
competitive exams do have a knack for
beating passion out of people by
cranking up the intensity and making the
pursuit of knowledge about winning
rather than about Joy or understanding I
hope that the students who are lucky
enough to participate in this event are
able to maintain and channel their
enthusiasm for the subject for non-
students if this stuff interests you
then maybe think about joining a local
astronomy club whole careers can be made
out of astronomy and astrophysics and
not just in the ways you might expect
I'm excited to introduce the sponsor of
this video a nonprofit called 80,000
hours they are not asking you to buy
anything they are trying to help you
find a career that might change the
world the name comes from the average
number of hours someone spends working
in their lifetime with all those hours
on the line it is worth devoting some
time to thinking about what you want to
spend your career doing backed by over a
decade of research alongside Oxford
University academics a 80,000 hours
recommends career paths with high social
impact that go beyond being a doctor
teacher or charity worker their advice
helps you to find a fulfilling career
that works for you and does good in the
world their co-founder studied physics
at Oxford before turning his attention
to altruism if you're watching my videos
you're probably interested in astronomy
physics math or science and these skills
are represented in any of the career
paths on the website such as software
engineering technical AI roles
biotechnology roles and even space
governance sign up for their newsletter
at 80,000 hour.org ties and you'll
receive a free in-depth career guide
plus they offer a job board with high
impact openings an insightful podcast
and free personal career advice it's all
fully philanthropically funded they
provide some really great resources so
go and have a look at 8000 hour.org
ties that link will also be down in the
[Music]
description